this morning candidates and surrogates
are sharpening their campaign message
with just 10 days to go until the
midterms last night President Biden vice
president Harris and former president
Obama were out in force as many polls
including our CBS News Battleground
tracker estimate Republicans are poised
to take the majority in the house with a
toss-up in the Senate Congressional
correspondent Nicole Killian is in
Atlanta where the former president held
a rally and Nicole there are more events
today
yeah that's right Jeff former president
of Barack Obama will travel to Michigan
and Wisconsin today the Nevada and
Pennsylvania next week he really spent a
lot of time last night addressing some
of the headwinds the party is facing
from inflation to Crime he told voters
democracy is on the ballot and urged
them not to be complacent
foreign
[Applause]
Friday hello Pennsylvania
Obama Biden both back on the trail at
the same time with the same message vote
vote vote I am here to ask you to vote
in Atlanta former president Barack Obama
highlighted Democrats closing argument
to rev up the base in his first midterm
campaign appearance tuning out is not an
option
despair is not an option
the only the only way to make this
economy fair is if we
all of us
fight for it former president rallied in
support of gubernatorial candidate
Stacey Abrams an incumbent Senator
Rafael Warnock taking several cracks at
his GOP opponent Herschel Walker seems
to me he's a celebrity who wants to be a
politician
the Georgia Senate contest is one of
several potential toss-up contests that
could determine control of Congress
along with Pennsylvania not hyperbole
suggest all eyes are on Pennsylvania but
some polls showing Republicans regaining
momentum Democratic Jitters Spilled Out
into the open this week when Majority
Leader Chuck Schumer was caught on a hot
mic with the president
[Music]
and we're gonna win period
each state voters eager to see the
former presidents that they were anxious
as election day nears I think that he
can only engender more support and we
keep on hearing about theirs low
engagement with the Democrats so I think
with him coming out he'll just energize
the base
Republicans plan to bring out their own
star power with former vice president
Mike Pence set to campaign here in
Georgia with Governor Kemp next week
former president Trump will also launch
a swing state Blitz right before the
election Dana
all right Nicole thank you